[Musique]
éloignez aux aguets à la recherche du
moindre détail suspect nous sommes à
Orly à l'arrivée d'un vol en provenance
de Cayenne en Guyane
tous les matins les mêmes questions
se poursuit et quelques instants plus
tard
quelque chose qui cloche pour l'instant
c'est une masse suspecte de couleur
blanche à peu près on doit avoir 500 un
peu plus de 500 le suspect est emmené
plus loin dans une petite salle après
vérification ce sont exactement
623 grammes qui ont été saisis le test
des douaniers passe du rose au bleu et
confirme l'évidence il s'agit bien de
cocaïne
cet homme est bien une mule un passeur
qui transporte de la drogue contre de
l'argent sur certains vols Cayenne Paris
il représente un passager sur 4 tous les
vols Cayenne on a deux vols par jour ici
on a des interpellations à chaque fois
quasiment tous les jours le profil type
de la mule c'est une personne masculin
qui à peu près 27 ans de nationalité
française mais également sur une amienne
brésilienne néerlandaise qui une fois
sur trois à des ovules incorporés
traduction qui avale des boulettes de
cocaïne enrobées de plastique au risque
de Loverdose y compris pour des mineurs
nous avons une fois interpellé une mère
de famille dans les deux fillettes
avaient ingéré également de la cocaïne
donc des fillettes de 11 et 15 ans et
qui est totalisait à L2 à peu près 40 au
vu de cocaïne ce matin là les douaniers
intercepteront aussi près de 7 kg de
cocaïne dissimulées dans le double fond
de cette valise il faut dire que pour
faire passer de la drogue les
trafiquants ont de l'imagination
coquille de noix carcasse de poisson
boîte de la liste est longue
pour comprendre les racines de ce fléau
il faut traverser l'Atlantique direction
la Guyane française l'aéroport de
Cayenne est l'une des principales portes
d'entrée des producteurs de cocaïne
sud-américains vers la France et donc
l'Union européenne
en Guyane les douaniers en sous-effectif
sont vite débordés mais font ce qu'ils
peuvent l'an dernier 512 murs ont été
arrêtés à l'aéroport pour une tonne et
demi de cocaïne saisie
c'est aussi le travail de la police en
ville cette nuit-là la BAC de Cayenne
patrouille à la recherche de ces
fameuses ovules de cocaïne regardez là
par exemple c'est là qu'on a fait les 4
kilos 5 des cocaïne on est rentré à la
poursuite d'un individu qui était
recherché pour de nombreux vols et on le
voit afin de confectionner des ovules il
avait l'appareil il avait deux pains de
cocaïne il était en train de
confectionner des ovules pour pour des
mules pour eux c'est devenu tellement
bagnole qui se promène avec quoi cette
fois-ci les fous une donnent rien mais
dans un département où plus de la moitié
des habitants vivent sous le seuil de
pauvreté les trafiquants de drogue n'ont
aucun mal à recruter des murs vous avez
besoin d'argent et que vous n'avez pas
la possibilité de travailler parce que
vous n'avez pas de papier parce que vous
ne voulez pas travailler tout simplement
c'est très facile d'accepter de prendre
l'avion et d'être payé pour transporter
de la rue salaire possible pour un
voyage selon elle autour de 5000 euros
là où il y a
il y a
est-ce qu'on
c'est exactement ce qui est arrivé à
Tonio polluxe
et avec un enfant à charge il devient à
son tour un passeur
vous voulez vous lancer dans un trafic
tout ça c'est pas le plus dur on a des
contacts du Suriname un peu partout il y
a même des contacts au Mexique
le trafic il est grand les vases il dit
avoir gagné jusqu'à 16000 euros pour
acheminer 800 g de cocaïne à Paris il
finit par être interpellé et purge un an
de prison à Fleury-Mérogis en fait c'est
à ce moment-là que je me suis dit non
virement incarcération tout ça je me
suis dit non c'est pas ma vie en fait
c'est pas ma vie
je peux pas faire je peux pas continuer
dans dans cette lancée en fait j'ai une
famille jeune fille si je veux qu'elle
grandisse dans de bonnes conditions il
faut pas que son père soit absent depuis
quelques mois une association
l'accompagne dans sa réinsertion à 27
ans il a aujourd'hui trouvé du travail
dans un magasin de plomberie